allez-vous déjà traversé un champ aussi
coloré aussi mouvementé qu'une coulée de
lave qui dégouline vers la mer avez-vous
déjà assisté au combat de titans que se
livrent quelques fois les flots le
rocher et le vent avez vous déjà servi
de trait d'union entre la lande et le
ciel avez vous déjà rencontré au détour
d'un chemin au coeur d'une forêt
profonde des personnages de légende
si oui vous vous êtes balader en
bretagne sinon il n'est jamais trop tard
pour bien faire
je vous y emmène
le rocher sur lequel nous nous trouvons
étant granodiorite est une roche dure
très dure
c'est sur cette roche qui a été bâti
fort la latte
ce fort date de 937 il était construit
là pour protéger les populations des
pirates normand qui venait écumé les
côtes
c'est également pour nous le point de
départ d'une randonnée d'environ trois
heures qui va nous conduire là bas venez
je vous emmène je vous montre
c'est en empruntant un petit sentier qui
longe les falaises que nous allons nous
rendre au cap fréhel
là-bas tout près du par se faire ficher
dans le grès rose
nous vous garantissons des paysages
extraordinaires mais terrifiant
jusqu'ici ça prend trois éléments le
vent l'eau et le rocher mais aussi nous
découvrirons la nature une nature qui a
réussi à s'implanter à s'adapter et qui
persiste ici c'est à la rencontre de
cette nature là que nous partons tout de
suite
il y a des goélands argentés ce sont les
plus nombreux il y a aussi des sternes
qui pêchent au quai des falaises et il y
a des cormorans tout noir qui feront le
lot il ne s'éloigne jamais des causes
on rencontre fréquemment sur ce sentier
des voûtes de végétation comme celle ci
et la plupart du temps cette végétation
est constitué de fougères haute bien sûr
et de prunellier c'est une végétation
qui pique sa pique le prunellier et
celui ci regardez sa forme on a
l'impression qu'il a été complètement
façonné par un jardinier en fait le
jardinier ici c'est le vent
vous n'aurez pas souvent l'occasion de
rencontrer des pins sur ce sentier parce
que le vent est trop violent ils ont
bien du mal à s'installer et ceux qui
sont là et bien sont très mal traités et
ça nous rappelle la violente tempête du
17 octobre 1987 qui a ravagé un bon
nombre de forêt bretonne les pins que
vous rencontrerez seront souvent affalé
et la plupart d'entre eux auront les
branches cassées
nous sommes à une demi heure de fort la
latte et de cet endroit à marée basse on
a très envie de rejoindre le cap fréhel
en empruntant le pied de la falaise
mais il y a des quantités de pièges à
éviter les petites plages que vous
pouvez voir en ce moment et bien sont
séparés reliées entre elles par des
petites falaises difficile à passer
l'escaladé est dangereuse la roche et
glissante pour atteindre ces plages il
est beaucoup plus prudent de partir du
sentier principal et de la prendre les
petites sentent qu'ils descendent en
prendre aide jusque vers le sable
lalande de fougères est maintenant loin
dans notre dos là-bas sur les falaises
couvertes
nous sommes maintenant dans la lande de
bruyère et d'agents et nous pouvons
encore rencontré des fougères dans les
creux humide mais cette fois en
compagnie de sol
la lampe du cap fréhel est l'une des
plus belles lampes du monde regardez
toutes les couleurs regarder toutes ses
formes toutes ces ondulations le jaune
ce sont des agents
attention ça pique celui ci est l'agent
de le gall et si vous êtes attentif si
vous prenez le temps de regarder
quelques fois avec un petit bouquin pour
les déterminer
vous rencontrerez différentes bruit hier
ici nous en avons 3 nous avons là le
plus commune la plus répandue
la brouillard cendré il ay ay si la
bruyère ciliées et la cacher derrière la
callune la fosse bruyère que l'on
rencontre aussi dans les tourbières
ça dit quoi
qu'est ce que vous demandez touriste qui
vous pose une question quand il va
rencontrer dans le phare il demande
surtout si vous si on est gardien de
vannes ce que si on me dit gay
maintenant je mets ma casquette de
travers le souhaitent
oui là je suis mauvaise humeur de la
journée après j'aime pas ça ah non c'est
une bavure sur la mer une bonne partie
toujours j'ai fait pas la marine
marchande innovants comme beaucoup
d'anciens gardiens pour nous c'est un
commerce ou une partie du temps c'est
une offense un petit peu la mule par
votre métier
ah oui c'est à moi j'aimerais ça à
personne d'autre mais c'était très dur
aussi attention à la wiimote et les
quinze jours une semaine de repos mais
s'ils avaient la tempête ça pouvait être
aussi bien 40 50 jours
oui c'était comme ça avec la développe
aux bretons en vain comme c'est le
relais fallon autre oeil comme ça le
système du bayer
il valait mieux c'est d'en faire
que sa vie comme on dit mais nous sommes
fonctionnaire très haut placées vos
enfants n'arrivent 1,95 mètre au dessus
du lot amer malheureusement cette étude
de style big one
s'il ya autant d'oiseaux de mer ici au
cap fréhel
c'est pas seulement parce qu'ils y
rencontrent une nourriture abondante
c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont l'occasion
de nicher dans des falaises verticale
bien protégé des visiteurs bien protégé
des gêneurs mais est aussi une autre
raison qui les pousse jusqu'ici regardez
le grès est empilé en couches
successives et ses couches sont presque
horizontal ce qui permet notamment aux
goélands argentés que vous voyez volée
et voltige et tout autour de ces blocs
de poser leur oeuf sur un sol qui va le
retenir il ne fait pas de nid
quelquefois simplement un petit creux
quand il ya un petit peu de terre alors
imaginez un petit peu un oeuf de
goélands posés sur un sol incliné c'est
l'omelette immédiatement alors on voit
les jeunes très distinctement parce
qu'ils ont un plumage gris beaucoup plus
sombre évidemment que les adultes qui
ont les ailes grises mais le reste du
corps tout blanc et ses jeunes on les
voit en ce moment en train de rentrer la
tête dans les épaules si j'ose dire
c'est un signe de soumission pour que
les adultes leur fiche la paix mais
s'est aussi d'une certaine façon pour
eux l'occasion de rappeler qu'ils
existent et ils viennent un peu
quémander de la nourriture
à
au gré quelquefois les adultes à
racheter des petits morceaux d'herbe et
les brandir dans le bec en regardant
droit dans les yeux
le voisin c'est une façon de lui dire
n'approche pas passez un pas de plus ils
sont menaçants avec l'horreur brindilles
sèches dans le bec et je vous assure que
ça marche puisque le voisin approche
quoi même quelquefois recul
alors nous retrouvons sur ces rochers le
cormoran huppé c'est cormorans huppés
ont perdu la huppe se retire parce que
c'est une parure nuptiale qu'ils
arborent au mois de décembre et les
jeunes bien sûr au printemps est bien
naissent ils ont un joli du v noirs et
là je viens de découvrir une anomalie
l'un d'entre eux est en train de couver
nous sommes mi juillet est-ce que vous
certifier que les yeux qui sont en train
d'être prouvé maintenant en plein milieu
du match d'hier ne donneront jamais de
poussins
ne vous laissez pas tenter par une
multitude de petits sentiers que vous
découvrirez sur le bord de la falaise la
plupart d'entre eux mêmes et des culs de
sac
vous serez le nez sur le rocher et
quelquefois même il se termine sur des
pelouses en pente glissante c'est très
dangereux pour vivre une découverte ici
il faut rester sur les sentiers balisés
cela suffit largement pour découvrir une
végétation d'une grande richesse et bien
entendu aussi la faune mais cette faune
elle est visible même de très très loin
bon
les cordons de dunes que nous allons
rencontrer au cours de cette promenade
son récent ça relativement il faut quand
même remonter quelques dizaines de
milliers d'années en arrière à l'époque
glaciaire quaternaire la dernière pour
connaître leur formation la mer était
très loin pour reculer sur plusieurs
kilomètres elle était probablement 40
mètres en dessous du niveau actuel
comment dit on ne la verrai pas d'ici y
avait un fort vent d'ouest se vent
d'ouest dans cette immensité découverte
poucet du sable jusqu'ici ce ça s'est
accumulé aujourd'hui sa forme un barrage
et ce barrage retient la plupart du
temps pas toujours des marais important
du côté de la terre
nous pouvons considérer que la balade a
commencé nous venons de franchir lance
du verger nous avons laissé les voitures
près du petit village qui se trouve en
haut nous sommes descendus à travers les
prunellier et maintenant nous filons
vers une plage on appelle la plage des
chevrets en gros 2h 2h30 de marche dans
un excellent sentiers
tout le long du sentier en corniche vous
rencontrerez sur le talus dans la
poussière pulvérulents des petits cônes
ce sont des cônes de 100 millions à
l'intérieur de ce cône à la base il y à
un monstre un estomac deux énormément
des bus qui sont là pour piéger les
fourmis elles descendent sur le bord du
cône et avec les mandibules il projette
ce fonds millions du sable il
déséquilibre la fourmi qui glissent
doucement d'enfants et là les mandibules
la saisisse
alors j'aime bien dans la main
et voilà la belle toute nue commencer un
petit peu mal à l'aise parce que je le
découvre et vous voyez il fait de la
marche arrière
ce que vous voyez bouger c'est en fait
son abdomen
vous avez dit c'est un monstre
imaginez une fourmi qui est saisie par
ses mandibules cette grosse larve quand
elle saura adule des ailes y auront
poussé et elle ressemblera la libellule
vous risquez peut-être même de l'avoir
volé à la fin de l'été
vous serez peut-être surpris de
rencontrer tout au long de ce sentier
qui longe la plage qui longe le bord de
la falaise des quantités énormes de
sureau je dis bien énorme vous en
rencontrez pratiquement partout et ce
sur roues est en compagnie de fougères
et d'agents pour ceux qui ne savent pas
encore reconnaître le sureau fiez vous
aux fruits ils deviendront très sombre
presque noir passion sa tâche ou
pourrait même en faire de la confiture
si vous avez encore un doute vous prenez
quelques feuilles sous les écraser dans
vos mains et vous sentez là vous allez
découvrir une odeur tout à fait
caractéristique celle du sureau vous
aurez peut-être la chance au cours de
cette balade de rencontrer sur le
sentier lui-même ce serpent de verre en
fait il s'agit d'un lézard dans les ars
en pâte seller mais il est très brillant
dans soleil il est métallique et celui
ci est la queue coupée probablement
parce qu'il a rencontré à renard ou un
touriste qui a essayé de l'attraper il a
libéré sa queue pour s'échapper la tête
de l'eau revêt c'est bien une tête de
lézard regardez sa petite langue qui
sort pour s'informer
est-ce que c'est froid ce que ce lycée
ce que c'est rugueux il est vraiment
inoffensif ne le fait pas il est très
utile il mangeait petit limaces il mange
des insectes et il a encore une
particularité il est ovovivipare cela
signifie qu'ils pondent des oeufs mais
que les aussitôt pondu libère des petits
or vais très bien constituer comme tous
les petits animaux que nous capturons
pour en parler nous les relâcherons
exactement à l'endroit où nous les avons
capturés et celui ci va donc regagné un
seul qui est meuble donc il aura
tendance à rentrer dans le sol mais en
règle générale vous pouvez le rencontrer
à condition qu'il fasse un petit peu
d'où un petit peu de soleil et vous le
verrez quelques fois sur les fougères
lorsqu'elles sont écrasés observer le
toucher du bout des doigts et vous le
verrez à ce moment là ils piquent de la
tête dans la végétation
il passe sous les fougères et très
rapidement il disparaît là n'essayez pas
de le prendre
vous aller lui casser la queue
nous sommes arrêtés dans un paysage qui
a bien aimé léo ferré puisqu'il a habité
quelques années dans cette splendide
demeure c'est aussi l'occasion de bien
comprendre juste à quel point ces dunes
littorales font obstacle à la marée
imaginez qu'une très forte houle
bouscule ce cordon littoral la mer
s'engouffre à l'intérieur des terres
c'est ce qui fait que ces dunes il faut
les protéger non seulement pour des
raisons écologiques mais également
évidemment aussi pour protéger les
cultures donc les hommes qui travaillent
là
le chardonnay bonjour vous assure ça
devait arriver jusqu'ici
en suivant le petit chemin côtier et
quelquefois nous passions sur les sur
les falaises et j'étais étonné de
trouver des étendues complètement de
terrain complètement retourné c'était
labourer le rouleau dépasser dessus des
terrains où ils valoir des choux fleurs
de plantes et d'ici une quinzaine de
jours
parce que maintenant il ne faut plus
qu'une récolte oui dans un second temps
fut autrefois il fallait des patates et
des fourrures après et les patates à
séoul a avalé patate mais on n'en fait
plus c'est vrai que ça vaut la peine
parce qu'il ya passé grandement le pas
ces derniers ont assez de rendement
c'est pour ça et les patates on l'a fait
du combien de temps dans la région
oh oui sûrement bien son temps
pressentant de perdre son temps leur ya
longtemps c'était une variété qu'on
appelait la fiuc géant que tu es la
seule variété qui existaient à l'époque
et qu'on vendait aux anglais l'écran
aller les porter à saint malo et ils
étaient commercialisés dans des magasins
et sa portée sur l'angleterre et vous en
faites encore goûté communauté un tout
petit peu moins que les autres bien
c'est une patate achats blanche qui
était ok très tendres donc elle sait
commercial dispute parce que s
c'est tout at-il se défaire frissons en
purée c'est l'arrêt ce chardonnay les
pommes de terre que vous ne nous montrer
là c'est un peu des reliques ses
dirigeants oui ces divers yeux mais
l'autre jour où me racontiez aussi
l'histoire de vestiges avaient un moulin
qui fonctionnait sur la marée a alloué
un moule m marc hé oui oui on lui peint
alors ce moulin là nos arrière grands
parents ils allaient apporter leur grain
à moudre à ce moulin et sa ferme et en
même temps cette digue de passage pour
les piétons qui voulait la femme alors
au ténor et fonctionner du bessin oui et
un petit peu de remontant jusqu'au temps
que la mer arrivait au pied de la digue
déclaré c'était fini forcément sort
finalement là l'usiné marémotrice c'est
pas nouveau l'idée sexuelle il ya bien
haut dans l'arrière du tout bois
ici le sable a rencontré un relief alors
il s'est accumulée à la base la dune
s'est formé ici
mais la dune et quand même menacé par le
vent très violent par la mer qui déploie
se déchaînent alors il existe une plante
la nature a bien fait les choses
d'autant qu'ils ne poussent que sur le
sable c'est l'oeil à ses racines est
profonde se ramifie et retiennent le
sable en profondeur et également sur
passe au fur et à mesure que le sable
s'accumulent le ja grimpe un petit peu
plus fx totalement cette dune
aujourd'hui on replante cet oeil à un
peu partout pour contenir le sable hier
cette plante existaient déjà et les
hommes l'utilisaient pour en faire des
paillassons dans lesquels qu'ils
installaient le fromage à sécher j'ai
rarement rencontré au cours de mes
balades des paniques aux marins ou faux
chardon autant coloré que celui ci il
faut évidemment faire très attention ne
marchait pas su vous en trouverez
quelques fois en dehors des zones
protégées
en tout cas ne les connaît pas ils sont
évidemment à conserver en cet état ce
sont des plantes piquante
regardez ces feuilles bleuté elles ont
de quoi se défendre ils sont en fleurs
et ça n'empêche pas les petits escargots
que l'on rencontre en grande quantité
ici sur cette dune de crapahuter
nous sommes partis ce matin par une mer
d'huile nous arrivons quatre heures
après toujours par une mer d'huile pas
un souffle de vent mais le rayonnement
solaire étaient toujours présents
attention protégez-vous bien la peau
nous avons profité d'une clarté tout à
fait exceptionnelle pour faire des
quantités de photos parce qu'à chaque
détour de criques ou deux pointes
rocheuses de paysage a changé
vous pouvez venir ici bien entendu en
famille même avec des tout petits
il faut faire très attention le chemin
et bien bordé par la végétation les
risques de chute sont vraiment très rare
mais il faut toujours avoir l'oeil sur
eux
bonjour bienvenue dans l'ouest de la
france
bienvenue dans les monts d'arrée pays le
mystère pays de légendes
nous sommes sur la commune de commana et
plus précisément au lieu dit les moules
go nous avons laissé les voitures un
petit peu plus loin sur le parking et
notre randonnée va nous permettre de
faire le tour d'un superbe lac on
appelle lac saint michel
mais le point de départ de notre balade
c'est ici près de cette superbe allée
couverte d'un dolmen sépultures
collectives datée d'environ 3000 à 2500
ans avant jésus-christ et je pense que
le fait de partir d'ici est un somptueux
présage notre balade sera certainement
riche et varié contrasté comme le temps
et vous avez probablement déjà reconnu
la lumière du finistère
ce que nous avons devant nous en fait
comme paysage ce sont simplement les
restes d'une vieille chaîne de montagne
la chaîne hercynienne lorsque l'on voit
aujourd'hui au niveau du lac saint
michel bien ce sont d'anciens marais
tourbeux qui ont été partiellement
inondées pour les besoins de ce
réservoir d'eau et cette dépression est
encadrée par des crêtes de roches dures
en fait sous la tourne sous les marques
les marécages tourbeuses il ya en fait
de schiste le schiste est une roche qui
est très très fragile qui a été dégagée
par l'érosion elle avoue n'être pas de
l'assistant du schiste non ici nous
sommes sur une petite partie de la crête
bordière du jeune cette crête elle est
constituée par une formation géologique
qu'on appelle la formation du grès
armoricain et localement ce gréement est
qu un faciès de coire dit à dire un
aspect de quartzite c'est une roche qui
est très très dur et qui correspond tout
simplement un ancien sable marin c'est
un sable durci et qui ici est datée à
460 millions d'années
il
bonjour oui là on vient de communes orb
ont été hébergés au gîte de commana et
donc on est parti ce matin est l'organe
donc le brésil 2 du lac saint michel et
on va se voir donc au gîte de brennilis
du principe de gîte en gîte de gitans et
1 ça fait cinq jours là qu'on est parti
en randonnée donc on fait tous les
mondes à rennes avec les ânes donc on a
les duels les couvertures lauriers car
voilà les gamins sont nés êtes
tranquille voilà voilà
sézanne ça ces gamins leurs gamins c'est
un grand noir du berry est derrière vous
avez donc victor1 qui est abonnée du
poitou n'était pas la pareille à la avec
des problèmes en live comme le baudet du
poitou elle est bien bonne balade moi je
continue mon côté y avoir au revoir à
les gamins en avant
je vous doit une explication je me suis
légèrement écartés des téméraires car
j'ai suivi denis j'ai été en effet
témoins de la scène suivante j'ai vu un
jeune homme a porté à denis infos qu'on
soit disant blessé ou malade alors denis
au premier abord
après avoir analysé française et d'un
père saupol de cassure évidente regarder
l'autre elle m'a l'air légèrement
affaibli il a peut être consommé une
sorte de poison ou alors il est sous
alimenté alors on va essayer de
déterminer mon l'espace déjà c'est un
faucon crécerelle raymond très bon l'air
en plumage juvénile basse et le plumage
humaniste s'apparente un peu à sud et
feu mâle adulte
voilà quelques critères pour déterminer
là on a affaire à un mal on aperçoit
bien la moustache c'est bien marqué un
mâle moustachu et puis à l'âge adulte à
partir de 2 ans environ
là que devient grise oui clair on voit
on commence déjà apercevoir les
premières plumes et le dessus de la tête
quand on rencontre un oiseau comme ça
sur le sol qui s'approchait qui se
laissent prendre
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire est ce qu'il
faut le prendre vraiment alors l'idéal
si on ne voit pas de blessure apparente
elle pendant deux pas de casser l'idéal
c'est de le mettre sur un an dro un
petit monticule
et puis de s'en aller car si les blessés
il faut le prendre délicatement le
mettre dans un carton et des chiffons ni
nourriture ni eau et le contacter au
plus vite un ornithologue une personne
compétente d'une association de
protection de la nature ou un organisme
comme le parc d'armorique denis en
est-elle l'arraché on va essayer votre
choix par mois une alerte de reprendre
un peu sa forme alors là c'est sur le
rocher plus vrai
vous rencontrerez ça votre chemin autour
du lac saint michel des tourbières
alors comment est ce qu'on les reconnaît
c'est pas compliqué du tout c'est un
lieu humide le terrain kassid donc l'eau
et acide et vous rencontrerez dans ce
milieu humide acide d'espagne des
mousses qui ne pousse que dans cet
environnement
c'est un milieu spongieux quand vous
allez marcher dessus vous allez vous
enfoncez très impressionnant faites
attention vous pouvez passer à travers
et ses mousses sont caractéristiques
regardez la base et sont de la partie
morte
c'est ce qui donnera plus tard la tourbe
quand on les regarde de très très près
on distingue très facilement toute une
série de cellules de certaines cellules
sont creuses et ses cellules piège l'eau
contiennent de l'eau jusqu'à 40 fois le
poids de la mousse regardez
quelques centimètres seulement au dessus
de la zone humide l'espagne sont sèches
elles ont perdu leur eau dès qu'il va se
remettre à pleuvoir
elles vont se gorger d'eau à nouveau
elles vont reverdir
elles joueront donc ce rôle
indispensable de réservoir toutes ces
tourbières les unes à côté des autres
formes une énorme éponge indispensable à
l'hydrologie de l'endroit car cette eau
qu'elles contiennent et progressivement
restituer pendant la saison sèche
je ne vous invite pas à randonner dans
la tourbière parce que c'est un milieu
difficile et dangereux et n'oubliez pas
que c'est un milieu également protégé si
nous sommes là c'est pour le coup d'oeil
admirez cette superbe tourbières bombay
en réalité cette tourbière est alimentée
que par la pluie ce qui fait que
l'espagne qui poussent sans arrêt vous
le savez est bien poussent vers le haut
c'est ce qui donne effectivement ce
mouvement au terrain le paysage est
constituée de petits arbres comme les
saules comme les bourdelle et on voit
aussi une plante qui est très visible en
ce moment parce qu'elle est en grain
façon les lits négrette regarder ce
petit duvet qui étaient utilisés
autrefois comme coton mais pas de
l'industrie textile parce que ce n'est
pas suffisamment rentable bien ce duvet
le vent le transporte
et au bout de chaque poule 2 du bec il y
a une petite graine c'est ainsi que les
lits négrette sont ensemencées autour de
nous
ce
ils veulent la place dans cette culture
j'avais de la place oui bah dans les
sépultures qui ont été fouillés en puis
calcaire on a trouvé jusqu'à 200 300
squelette dont ce type le minimum
c'était quand même assez configurable et
c'est vraiment une structure collective
alors ça c'est un dolmen
c'est un dolmen dolmen parmi tant
d'autres un dolmen intermédiaire entre
les dolmens la couloire d'une ancienne
eolithic armorica et les allées
couvertes comme celle de commana c'est
une squatteuse une sépulture enlevé
parce que lorsque l'on rentre l'entrée
est étroite elle fait un mètre de large
et lorsqu'on arrive au front et fait
deux mètres cinquante de mettre 60
dollars mais dans les livres scolaires
quand on parle de dolmen on voit des
pires dresser une table sur le dos à oui
alors ça c'est le squelette du dolmen
c'est le dolmen qu'on appelle dolmen
pour touristes de leurs visiteurs ce
n'est que la partie interne du domaine
le domaine est fait pour les morts bien
sûr pour m nous faire des innovations
mais aussi pour les vivants et un dolmen
comporte deux parties la partie interne
qui est composé de pilier et de tables
de couverture et le tout est enseveli
sous un tertre et la plupart du temps
enterré par une petite enceinte de
pierres dressées comme apple intériste
et rythme on voit très bien ici lorsque
le légendaire s'est mis en place sans
doute très tôt dès le moyen âge on ne
savait pas quelle était l'origine le but
est la fonction de ses monuments
mégalithiques que ce soit les menhirs
que ce soit les dolmens et on a attribué
sa à des génies à des géants adena à des
farfadets des trolls des korrigans ici
par part contre ces monuments s'appelle
pierre boudigues est qui en français
veut dire la maison des faits on pensait
que c'était les effets qui avait
construit et qui habitait dans ce
monument est alors que à commana on
l'appelle tiko reagan est donc la maison
des korrigans
alors il ya même une petite légende
locale ici qui dit que les korrigans
decaux mona ne s'entendait pas avec ceux
de brennilis et elle est marrante cette
histoire là et comme ils ne
s'entendaient pas se jeter des cailloux
et les cailloux ils sont jetés tellement
qu'ils se rencontraient en l'air et ils
tombaient entre les deux monuments et
c'est ce qui a construit à la chaîne des
monts d'arrée et que c'est une légende
absolument acte ordinaire et qui a duré
et donc pendant très longtemps vivent
que pour créer la chaîne des monts
d'arrée il a fallu jeter quand même une
sacrée quantité
il y a du monde un crapaud un crapaud
commun est une femelle elle est effrayée
elle se gonfle pour m'impressionner
ainsi pour marc bret c'est un petit
bijou ici dans la lande
c'est un très très bel animal celui ci
est jeune ce sont des animaux qui ne
connaissent l'eau que pendant l'instant
de la reproduction c'est dans l'eau que
se développent leurs larves
c'est un animal inoffensif que l'on peut
effectivement trouver en soulevant des
pierres comme celle ci mais je vous
rappelle que c'est un animal extrêmement
protégé il est prohibé de se déplacer
vécu dans le coffre de la voiture
il est très très bien protégé par la loi
des crapauds accoucheurs les uns
derrière les autres
regardez ce sont des mâles eux aussi
préfèrent la terre ferme
quand la femelle pond elle est sur la
terre loin de l'eau les mâles ensuite
entortille les pourtours des pattes
arrière et les promène comme ça dans la
campagne loin de l'eau quand les eaux
sèche
ils vont tranquillement rejoindre l'eau
ils les mouiller
il ressort qu'ils rejoignent la pierre
il rejoint un endroit sec il est
transporte 1 6 3 6 semaines sur leur dos
quand ils sont près de l'éclosion
ils rejoignent l'eau il dépose les yeux
dans l'eau et aussitôt les larmes
s'échappe
ce sont deux tout petits crabes où il
mesure 5 cm maximum
ils sont très fragiles et aussi son
protégé on n'a pas le droit de les
ramasser
le sentier de randonnée empreinte le
sommet d'un talus c'est une limite de
propriété je suis dans l'ancien
parcellaire derrière moi autrefois la
tourbière était immense halle occupé
toute la dépression en 1930 un barrage
pour alimenter une centrale
hydroélectrique une partie de la
dépression est noyé à la fin les années
1960 c'est la première centrale
nucléaire de france qui s'installe ici à
la fin des années 1980 on commence à la
démanteler avec un peu de chance à la
fin des années 90 nous n'aurons
complètement oublié cette étendue de
tourbières étaient est aujourd'hui
encore chargé d'histoire parce que les
gens qui fréquentaient cette tourbière
tous les gens qui devaient traverser le
marais pour soi pour aller pour pour
passer du nord au sud
ou alors aller au pardon de rumengol par
exemple les pèlerins craignait cette
traversée parce que de tous temps on a
situé la un endroit particulièrement
dangereux où les gens quand ils s'y
aventuraient les bêtes en casale la
s'enfonçait et disparaissaient c'est cet
endroit là qu'on appelait le but dit le
youdec c'est un mot breton qui veut dire
bouillie lieu plus exactement gabegie du
vix est un diminutif de tout ce qui se
termine en est comme ça en breton c'est
un diminutif ça veut dire petite bouille
à nos anciens ont utilisé ce mot là pour
désigner cet endroit où les gens quand
ils y allaient le tenez pas dessus ils
ont imaginé il c'est toujours comme ça
en breton quand on n'a pas de mot pour
désigner quelque chose on a toujours
recours à une image et si c'est le cas
ils ont pris un
ils ont imaginé un grand chaudron de
bouillie sur lequel vous la fais
quelques durs de loup ça s'enfonce tout
doucement et ça disparaît alors quand on
disait aux petits-enfants d'antan cité
passage dont on verra au violet qui
comprenait tout de suite et pas de
problèmes et de tout temps on a parlé
tous les grand barde breton qui ont
écrit des choses sur la bretagne ont
tous parlé
du ludique et des portes de l'enfer
parce que les geeks le ludique est
devenu le porte les portes de l'enfer
mais avant ça s'appelait les celtes
appeler ça déjà les portes de l'autre là
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait pareil
et aujourd'hui encore personne dans la
région ne peut se vanter d'avoir été aux
yeux des aidants est revenu c'est assez
extraordinaire et c'est pour ça que cet
endroit est encore chargé d'histoire et
lorsqu on randonne sépaq pas des
sentiers de randonnée pour recevoir un
tourisme de masse
mais c'est un une cuvette qui n'a pas
été touché ni par les cultures
intensives ni par les élevages intensifs
ce qui fait que on y trouve des plantes
une faune et une flore assez
extraordinaire avec des variétés qui ont
disparu depuis longtemps ailleurs et
pour celui qui se donne la peine de
regarder d'écouter d'entendre le sentir
c'est un lieu magique
le grain c'est tout brocéliande en fin
de compte je dis souvent aux visiteurs
que chacun a son propre graal
chacun se dirige bien sûr bien pour sa
vie soit meilleur envers les autres et
pour lui-même et le graal est bien en
fin de compte c'est ça car si on
réfléchit bien quand galade le fils de
lancelot a trouvé le graal
il est mort donc en fin de compte est ce
que le graal c'est pas aussi
l'aboutissement de toute une vie le
graal est présent partout dans l'église
il ya là qu'on peut voir et d'autres
qu'on peut découvrir et on peut aussi
passer devant certains tableaux où il
est présent dans le voit points on dit
souvent qu'il faut rentrer en pro
saignante sur la pointe des pieds car
c'est vrai que c'est pas un lieu
ordinaire
les celtes disait que c'était d'ailleurs
leur cathédrale donc c'est vrai il faut
aussi rentrer dans le mystère tout
doucement au départ en ayant dans la
tête
bien sûr tout de suite l'imaginaire tous
ces personnages du mythe arthurien
bonjour et bienvenue à tréhorenteuc
soyez rassuré nous sommes venus chercher
des clés qui vont nous permettre
d'investir à pas de loup la forêt de
brocéliande sans prendre le risque de
rencontrer la fée morgane
nous sommes à la limite de la forêt de
paimpont
elle recouvre environ aujourd'hui 7000
hectares au 1er siècle après
jésus-christ elle s'étendait sur 140 km
de long il existe d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui des îlots qui seront faits
des vestiges de cette époque la forêt
que nous allons visiter ensemble
maintenant c'est un de ces îlots le plus
vaste cela forêt de brocéliande
vous êtes prêts nous y allons
derrière cette barre de schiste rouge
lancelot a dû affronter deux dragons
traverser un étang où l'eau bouillonnait
franchir un mur de flammes pour
rejoindre le château imaginaire de la
fée morgane
en septembre 1990 ici c'était la
fournaise lalande brûler la forêt était
en feu nous sommes au point de départ
d'une randonnée qui va nous conduire
dans un site fantastique merveilleux le
val sans retour
les habitants de la forêt de brocéliande
nous donne une leçon
ils ont érigé un monument à la mémoire
des arbres morts au feu cela montre à
quel point la forêt est importante pour
eux à quel point les arbres font partie
de leur univers et cela me rappelle une
anecdote que j'ai vécu en amazonie
lorsqu'un ami à me dit tu sais lorsque
la forêt aura disparu les indiens au
site
voilà le miroir des faits sur lequel
aujourd'hui ne se répète plus que
l'image des arbres les libellules et
demoiselles
sur le bord du sentier il ya dix ans
attention ça pique c'est une plante que
l'on connaît depuis le néolithique
elle occupe tous les milieux laissés
vacants dans la nature ces fruits
servent à faire un sirop pectoral et ses
feuilles si vous lui récolté fait sans
une tisane
plus tard peut-être des gargarismes qui
permettront de lutter contre les angines
si l'envié vous prend de remonter le
rocco par son lit attention de ne pas
vous tâchez la montagne regorge de
minerais de fer et l'eau charrie la
rouille
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui explique ici
elle à la présence de mines de fer à
ciel ouvert et de forge un peu partout
qui aujourd'hui malheureusement ne
fonctionne plus le long du sentier avant
d'attaquer le rocher ou longerait un
bassin c'est en fait réservoir d'eau qui
servait à alimenter un moulin dont vous
trouverez les ruines plus bas près de
l'arbre d'or et votre oeil exercé pourra
peut-être franchir la surface de l'eau
et découvrir des pertes nettes
ici sur sur cette zone de l'enilia un
cycle d'un incendie en 1976 tout le
point était complètement décimée par le
feu et ce qui est intéressant c'était de
voir justement cette nature qui surfeuse
est un petit peu de d'elle-même avec
d'abord les sur les zones incendiées on
voit apparaître les les fougères
certaines certaines herbes et puis après
une multitude de boulot et ensuite les
pins qui reviennent à leur tour et puis
ensuite il ya une espèce des équilibres
de la nature qui se fait et certaines
espèces qui prennent qui prennent le
dessus sur sur d'autres et tout un décor
qui se qui se recréer 15 ans après on a
on a vraiment plus le souvenir de
d'incendié cet endroit là jusqu'à ce que
malheureusement un autre une autre
catastrophe une ressurgissent c'est ce
qui s'est passé en 1990 où le où le
secteur que nous voyons ici a à nouveau
complètement été décimée
quand le feu passe la végétation est
entièrement détruite
le vent souffle les particules les plus
légères la pluie d'élèves le sol les
rochers sont mis à nu les particules les
plus fines les plus riches se retrouvent
dans des dépressions
elle forme un sol plus brin plus riches
en valeur nutritive
c'est là que s'installe le jeune et à
balai et quelquefois la fougère un peu
plus haut le sol est beaucoup plus
pauvres
on y retrouve des graminées on y
retrouve des agents et bien voilà le
genêt c'est le jeune et à balai c'est un
arbuste tout à fait indispensable de la
région grâce à sa présence
je sais que sous mes pieds j'ai un seul
brin d'environ 30 centimètres jusqu'à
même peut-être 50 cm il a besoin d'être
solidement enracinée il est utile parce
que c'est un courage qui sert aussi bien
aux animaux sauvages auxerre par exemple
également aux moutons et aux chèvres
il est utile pour une autre raison parce
que dans ses racines
il ya un dispositif qui contient des
bactéries qui fixent l'azoté de
l'atmosphère
et quand la plante meurt et bien cet
azote est donné est restituée au sol
alors ces graines vous les connaissez
elles sont ici elles sont contenues dans
des gauches et quand ses goûts ça arrive
à maturité elle se vrille
ce qui produit une sorte d'explosion et
les graines sont semées
elles sont ici s'égrènent les graines
qui tomberont sur le sol aujourd'hui le
germeront que l'année prochaine
et chose très pratique on sait que
s'égrènent gardent leur pouvoir de
germination au moins pendant 25 ans ce
contexte le genêt est très utile venez
suivre et moi nous allons visiter une
parcelle de terrain recoloniser par le
boulot
recoloniser parce qu'ici le feu est
passé plusieurs fois mais à chaque fois
la nature a repris le dessus
les premiers arrivés ce sont les arbres
pionniers ce sont les boulots landgren
sont très petites elles sont
transportées par le vent elle se sème
jusqu'ici il se développe très
rapidement ils sont très utiles parce
que leurs racines chrétiennes le sol et
le feuillage fait de l'ombre
et du coup cet ensemble permet des
végétaux comme ici le chêne à croissance
beaucoup plus lent de s'installer et de
croître
il arrivera un moment où les boulots
vont se densifier ils vont se gêner
certains vont mourir ils vont se
décomposer ils feront de l'humus utile
aux autres plantes plus tard encore
comme la durée de vie du boulot et très
courte et bien ils finiront par mourir
et par laisser la place aux arbres plus
importants comme le chêne qui lui par
contre est un véritable parfum
pour accélérer le mouvement pour donner
du tonus à la nature les hommes
fondé par feu ils labourent le sol ce
qui a pour effet d'en fermer les
graminées de les enterrer donc elles ne
peuvent plus transmettre le feu mais du
coup ça permet au boulot de s'installer
beaucoup plus confortablement les hommes
n'ont plus qu'à planter des chênes ici
du chêne d'amérique à croissance rapide
et le tour est joué
nous sortons maintenant du val sans
retour c'est donc la preuve que le
charme de la fée morgane est rompu et
nous partons rejoindre la forêt de
paimpont beaucoup plus dense beaucoup
plus sombre les avant de partir je
m'interroge sur l'état de la nature ici
qui est souvent a ravagé par les
incendies je me demande si elle ne
révèle pas quelques similitudes avec les
incendies qui ravagent la savane
africaine
n'oubliez pas que les rebelles et faons
c'est aussi une graminée la quelle
distance se trouve la vraie vraie sent
bon la forêt à deux fois ici c'est
l'antichambre
ici il suffit de il suffit de s'engager
dans dans le fond de nouvelles sortes ou
même sur les crêtes et puis petit à
petit vous rentrez dans la forêt en fait
vous savez ici il n'ya pas de ya pas de
frontières bien bien délimiter la
frontière ont cela fait soi même
il ya une inscription sur la porte de
l'église de tréhorenteuc qui parlent
plus que tout discours il est marqué la
porte est en dedans et ma foi ça veut
dire que cette porte invisible c'est à
chacun de l'ouvrir pour pénétrer dans ce
qu'on appelle l'autre monde
le franchir la lisière de l'autre monde
alors ma foi la lisière de l'autrement
de la lisière de la forêt allez vous
voulez bien placé
la forêt de paimpont et kim ans elle est
profonde elle et des royantes allée
sombre aussi elle est sombre parce que
les arbres sont puissants ce sont
surtout des chaînes d être les
châtaigniers des merisiers qui développe
au dessus de notre tête des houppiers
très importants dont les feuilles sont
extrêmement vorace en lumière mais ces
arbres très puissant très grands qui
peuvent perdre jusqu'à 40 mètres de haut
ont cependant les pieds allons envoyer
au frais c'est la strack la plus
importante
en dessous il y à la strate arbustives
constituée de jeunes arbres qui à leur
tour se dépêchent de regagner la lumière
qu'il ya des petits arbustes comme par
exemple ici le ou en dessous encore à
ras du sol on trouve les mousses on
trouve les champignons on trouve
quelques herbes on trouve des fougères
c'est ce qu'on appelle la strate
herbacée mais il n'empêche que tous ces
végétaux bbc parce que le sol est riche
et le sol est riche parce que le nu
c'est sans arrêt reconstitué
le chêne est un arbre très bien
représentée ici il est connu par les
hommes depuis très longtemps
certainement parce qu'il est très beau
il est un peu différent des autres il
s'élève sur un tronc puissance et
branches tordues et son ou pillées
s'étale c'est un art donc que les hommes
respectent
non seulement parce qu'il est beau mais
aussi parce qu'il est très utile son
bois est très dur et son écorce contient
du tanin le tan qui est utilisé
aujourd'hui dans l'industrie du cuir de
luxe provient de les corses de chaîne
cette écorce fait dans des décoctions
vous pourrez ainsi combattre des
inflammations et des diarrhées
vous pouvez également l'utiliser d'une
autre façon toujours pas décoction ou
l'étaler sur les brûlures autre légende
lure et ça vous soulage les corses
encore une fois est bien contient un
bactéricide que l'on rencontre encore
aujourd'hui dans certains médicaments
promener les chiens le passé
autrefois la flore et un pont devait
être très bruyant il y avait une
activité humaine danse
il y avait des gens qui venaient
ramassaient du bois il y avait des
animaux en pâturage il y avait même des
mines à ciel ouvert comme ici c'est un
vestige de carrière de laquelle on
sortait le minerai de fer on pouvait
l'imaginer pas très loin d'ici
des chantiers on abattait le mois et ont
fabriqué le charbon de bois donc à vous
de trouver en vous promenant dans cette
forêt les emplacements de ces anciennes
phare monnières tout lieu de brocéliande
fait partie de la forêt légendaire de la
forêt sacrée il faut pas croire que le
la foule a legend se cantonne sur
quelques points
répertorier et peut-être trop fréquenté
tout site de la forêt appartient cette
légende est aussi de la forêt peut-on
rêver a été traversée par lancelot
viviane lors d'années et toute la
chevauchée des chevaliers de la table
ronde et ses légendes justement voulait
rencontrer lorsque vous vous promenez
dans la forêt vous retrouverez des
endroits des sensations louison des
sensations sûrement mais c'est toujours
tellement difficile de faire la part de
ceux qu'on porte en soi et comme qu'on
veut rencontrer et de ce qu'il ya
vraiment mais je crois quand même qu'on
est trop nombreux à éprouver quelque
chose de différent quelque chose c'est
très subtil ce n'est pas du tout de
l'ordre de l'équation du rationnel et je
ne devais même pas cherché à me prouver
parce que c'est au ressenti de chacun
qu'on découvre la légende mais les la
ccc certains puisqu'elle est en
brocéliande
on peut se dire que merlin l'enchanteur
et partout dans la forêt puisque la
légende nous dit que c'était un des
lieux qui les met à fréquenter merlin
est un homme de
cour du roi arthur mais c'est surtout un
homme de la forêt c'est à sa manière
l'esprit de la forêt et toutes les
forêts essentielle mais on nous raconte
dans les courbes dans les livres dans
les vieux roman on nous raconte qu'il
avait une prédilection pour brocéliande
entre autres parce qu'il rencontrait
celle qu'il aimait viviane et viviane
finit par l'enfermer dans la forêt de
brocéliande et de ce jour on ne sait
plus où il est dans la forêt voilà une
des légendes justement une des versions
du conte qui nous expliquent qu'il est
dans le tronc du plus gros arbres de la
forêt
c'est peut être bien celui-là de moi je
crois surtout qu'il est dans la forêt en
général
et vous savez merlin de par sa naissance
fabuleuse a été doté de pouvoirs et
entre autres pouvoir à celui de changer
de forme
rien ne dit qu'il a perdu ce pouvoir en
était enfermée dans brocéliande
donc je crois vraiment qu'on peut le
rencontrer à tout instant à tout moment
n'est parce qu'il est né relais on ne
reconnaît jamais est ce que les hommes
d'aujourd'hui sont encore inquiétés par
marin les hommes d'aujourd'hui ce
devrait être inquiété par merlin ne
serait ce que pour tout ce qu'il faut à
la nature moi je ne sais pas c'est des
zones sont encore inquiétés par merlin
mais les hommes sont encore attiré
sûrement parler les jambes dans merlin
le centre ici à brocéliande